the U.S Senate unanimously condemned
China yesterday over the Spy balloon
down nearly two weeks ago now after it
flew from China across the continental
U.S Republicans including Florida
Senator Marco Rubio have strongly
criticized President Biden's response to
the balloon the first of four flying
objects shot down this month four
Senator Rubio is a top-ranking
republican on the Senate intelligence
committee and a member of the Foreign
Relations Committee and we're happy to
say he's joining us this morning Senator
it's good to see you good to see you I
know you've had several briefings about
this matter in the last couple of days
what can you share with us about what
you've learned and how concerned should
the American people be first share with
us what you've learned yeah I think it's
important to separate two different and
distinct incidences or two different
types of incident the first is the
balloon everybody saw it we knew what it
was we've seen them before the U.S knew
it was coming and knew it was headed
here it knew at least the day before it
entered U.S airspace what it was going
to be doing and had the opportunity to
shoot it down did not it entered the U.S
through Idaho traveled through the
middle of the country over some very
sensitive and important military
installation some of the most important
we have in the country exited off the
coast of South Carolina it was shot down
and they're recovering that was a spy
balloon and we've never seen to do what
that one did but we have seen it as
they've been testing it around the world
and so forth then you have the other
three the other three we don't know what
they are they don't know what they are
they haven't told anybody they haven't
told us what it is they may not know
themselves and potentially may never
know those incidents the three objects
as they called it are actually not
unprecedented there have been hundreds
and hundreds of reports almost identical
to these over the last few years not
about flying saucers it's about small
Vehicles operating and often restricted
airspace but what is unusual is that
this is the first time in American
history 65 years since NORAD was set up
that we've shot anything down not to
mention three things over three days
last weekend and so I do think that
merits the president directly addressing
why those things were shot down and what
we know up to this point nothing they've
talked to us about with regards to those
three should be classified because
there's really not the type of thing you
classify Senator based on what you know
is the United States prepared to deal
with what it can now see are objects in
the sky on a fairly routine basis
I would say the answer is no look if you
go back I encourage everyone I know
people don't follow this closely but
there's an agency called arrow that was
created by Senator Jilla Brandon New
York and myself and others and it
monitors all of these anomalous
incidents which is basically aircraft
flying in places they don't belong and
we don't know who it belongs to there
are hundreds of these cases being
reported we don't do a good job of
monitoring we don't have a systemized
way to respond to it and the difference
between these three and hundreds of
those cases is these three were shot
down that's the biggest difference so
right now and if you're a small craft
moving slowly perhaps maneuvering in
ways we're not used to seeing at twenty
twenty five thirty thousand feet the US
really doesn't have an established
protocol for how to monitor that or
address it until NORAD decided to turn
on his Radars and look for it at that
level the budget Administration is still
being criticized for not shooting down
the balloon earlier and their pushback
to that is listen we wanted to make sure
that it was in a safe area that American
lives weren't at stake do you not
believe that that explanation
no they had an opportunity to shoot it
down before it entered U.S airspace
before it even got over Alaska they knew
where it was headed they had been
tracking it we have we knew well in
advance at least a day before it entered
at U.S airspace we knew where it was
headed and we had an opportunity to
confront it then and failed to do so and
now this thing what it did is it went
right through the middle of the country
and unlike other similar flights by
these balloons it didn't just go over a
piece of Florida for 30 minutes on its
way across the Equator this one hung
over the right diagonally cross through
the middle of the country and over
places like strategic command sensitive
missile Fields my senses they probably
collected all sorts of signals
intelligence and imagery that approved
valuable to the Chinese Communist party
yeah and um so they had a chance to stop
it before it did all that how is this
affecting U.S Chinese relations and and
on that point though Gail there seems to
be daylight between what the White House
is saying that there's been no effect
and then what the Pentagon has said
which is that Chinese counterparts would
not even take a call from our defense
secretary that's a sounds like a pretty
cool relation so where are things really
and where do they need to go going
forward well the United States and China
are engaged in great power competition
that's been the way the world has been
for all but the last you know 30 years
but that which is an anomaly but the
world has always had great powers that
compete against each other and the hope
is you can avoid that turning into a
military conflict but we will be
competitors with China technologically
commercially geopolitically and Military
from our capable capability perspective
for the rest of our lifetimes this
entire Century will be defined by that
competition yeah so yeah the Chinese are
complaining and stuff but they know it's
their balloon Senator I want to get your
thoughts on a problem that seems to be
uniquely American and we're talking
about mass shootings in the recent week
we've had El Paso and also Michigan
State there have been more mass
shootings than days of the year 71 to be
exact why do you think this is a U.S
problem
well the problem is really mass murder
and the guns are the instrument they use
on a lot of these murders they're but
mass murder is really the core issue why
do people decide I'm going to kill a
bunch of people some of whom are
strangers and that's a real fundamental
challenge there you know there's a lot
of Science and study out there written
about it there are some key indicators
of what leads someone to do that I mean
they're invariably young males
oftentimes have shown signs well in
advance with the exception of the
shooting in Las Vegas every single one
of these was someone who was
telegraphing that they were headed
Direction so the ability to intervene
before they take action is really
critical I understand what you're saying
and I'm not being dismissive to those
with mental health issues but after the
shooting at Parkland High School five
years ago you showed willingness to
support stricter gun legislation but
then voted against it
um a gun Reform Bill this past summer so
have your stance changed on how you look
at restricting gun laws well that's not
an accurate description of what I voted
against what I voted against was bill
that didn't protect people's fundamental
rights I'm in favor of red flag laws I'm
not in favor of red flag laws that allow
your neighbor who has a problem with you
to go down to the courthouse and have
your gun taken away I think it should be
law enforcement that does it like the
law is in Florida this law provided
federal funding for laws across the
country that would allow a neighbor A
co-worker anyone really to go down to a
courthouse because they have a personal
beef and give you a hard time about your
ownership of a gun and so I'm not in
favor of a law that does that right I am
in favor of one that allows family
members to go to law enforcement and say
my relative is threatening to kill
themselves they own a gun we can't
legally take it away from them unless
there's a court order to do so to
protect them perhaps others I continue
to support that I've offered that I've
filed bills to do that that are
bipartisan they just chose to go in a
different direction
aren't you tired of this story too in
less than 30 seconds yes it's clear what
what we have on the books right now
isn't working aren't you tired of these
stories as we all are
yeah and one of the reasons why it's not
working is because we don't enforce
these laws this individual in the latest
shooting actually had gun charges in the
past so that's the first point I would
make the second is that the leading
cause of gun death in America after
suicide is Street violence where these
guns are being sold on the black market
and so the fundamental question goes
back to this why are young people in
America willing to murder people we have
story people get shot every day in our
parts of South Florida where I live so
go out and shoot up a house they didn't
buy that at a gun show or at a gun store
they're buying it off the street and
they're killing people without any
regard for human life and that's the
core issue that we're confronting yeah
and I just know we're all sitting here
frustrated and nothing seems to change
but we thank you senator for your time I
know we'll talk again thank you